Jerry Cohen the president of Carnegie
Mellon University is by tremendous
pleasure and honor to welcome you here
to this very important event when we
honor the seventh president of Carnegie
Mellon Robert Arabian with the
dedication of this building in his name
the high quality of our undergraduate
experience educating the whole student
is well known now in the US and abroad
Robert came to CMU intending to focus on
undergraduate education and went about
it in the typical Robert fashion Robert
recognized also the value of Arts in all
education and serious strength in the
arts and our unique position in all
higher education as a top research
university with the conservatory quality
College of Fine Arts he recognized the
potential for combining these strengths
in our highly interdisciplinary
environment a recognition that has led
to unique creative collaborations
between technology in the arts here like
nowhere else I often describe Carnegie
Mellon as an electric place I feel a
palpable energy in the air when I am
here to me this electricity is truly the
embodiment of the innovative
collaborative inquisitive approach to
learning that is Carnegie Mellon in his
time as president dr. moravian was both
a source and a conductor of this
electricity providing the spaces and
places the institutional support and the
vision for us to be electric and we
alumni are grateful for his leadership
and his passion for Carnegie Mellon
thank you today we're dedicating a
building that focuses on another element
of your legacy one that impacts not only
our university but the entire Pittsburgh
region you played a central role in
setting a course to revitalize our
regional economy
now naming the collaborative innovation
center is the Robert Mehrabian
collaborative innovation center
recognizes and celebrates not only what
you did for our University for what you
did for our region as well one of the
characteristics that those of us who
worked with Robert mill is good enough
was never good enough and he carried
that same message through to the region
so he looked at what was going well in
the region and the progress that we've
made and said it's not good enough we
can do better we need to do better and
we need to work together to do that and
that spirit really has helped to propel
the region forward and to find the time
to take the time that Robert did just to
go out into the communities of
Pittsburgh to sell the idea that we
could enjoy technology-based economic
development if only we could work
together I'm not quite sure how he did
it but he did do it and the results have
been spectacular as you know yet another
reason why this is such a fitting
building to have Roberts name on it
because it really is the heart the
landing spot if you will for some of the
world's great technology companies as
they come to Pittsburgh and I'm going to
read this quickly but i do want to read
it because it's important i'm doing this
on behalf of the board of trustees of
carnegie mellon which passed the
following resolution whereas at the
recommendation the president the provost
the board of trustees wishes to
recognize and honor the achievements of
Robert Arabian now therefore be it
resolved that Carnegie Mellon University
here by names the collaborative
innovation center as the Robert
Mehrabian collaborative innovation
center in recognition of President
rabens many contributions to the
University and the region
okay you have to do that again because
please welcome back the 7th president of
Carnegie Mellon University Robin
Moravian
thank you very much Jerry and everyone
you've been most gracious and too loud
to hear of what I have done or what I
did let me just say a few words about
tech transfer as I knew it then but i'll
give you one example there was a guy at
Carnegie Mellon was in computer science
he was a researcher his name was fuzzy
because of his hair his last name was
mauled in fuzzy was the guy who wrote
the cold four lipos lycos was a search
engine the first one of the two first
search engines are this day I didn't
understand it but I had enough of a
conception of it to understand that this
was something bigger than what we could
handle and live an out and we got a
venture capital firm to put in some
money that was 1995 in 96 it went public
very quickly at the same time Yahoo was
founded in 95 and he went public in 96
but same time in the public offering we
raised i think it was 270 million
dollars about that anyways are ten
percent was about 20 22 23 million
dollars it's very interesting we have
life and technology and innovation and
collaboration how it works sometimes at
the best of times you can be very
successful but to continue to innovate
and to achieve it's become so important
last thing about the Pittsburgh in 2011
the number of jobs in Pittsburgh grows
by 2% one of the highest in Hindman
metropolitan region and certainly twice
the rate that the nation of national job
creation was so Pittsburgh is a vital
creative environment and Carnegie Mellon
University
a of Pittsburgh that played a great role
but it's the leadership in Pittsburgh
that's played a great role it was very
interesting I very recently read a
little editorial report about pittsburgh
but he was really talking about
dysfunction in Washington from weather
is the administration or Congress was
dysfunctional it said at a time when
America needs a blast of inspiration to
remember the value of common purpose and
the need to work together to solve
problems we can find in Pittsburgh story
a constructive way forward thank you
you